las mujeres estadounidenses llevaron a
las calles y la lucha por el aborto este
sábado con pancartas y lemas a favor de
los derechos reproductivos a lo largo de
todo el país
en
nuestro gobierno y los hombres no tienen
nada que decir cuando se trata de
nuestros cuerpos además las personas que
no apoyan el derecho de las mujeres a
decidir son las mismas que no creen en
los programas sociales para cuidar de
los niños no deseados
la ira fue desatada a raíz de la
aprobación de una ley en texas que
prohíbe el aborto a partir de las 6
semanas cuando muchas mujeres ni
siquiera saben que están embarazadas y
se ha avivado con la revisión de la roe
versus wait el caso que permitió que la
interrupción del embarazo fuera
considerado como un derecho
constitucional hace casi 50 años
pierce ya llevan casi 50 años intentando
acabar con la ley de roe versus wave y
seré honesta cuando pasó pensé que la
corte suprema- la iba a tumbar otra vez
y como no lo hicieron tenemos que luchar
él
las manifestaciones feministas se dan un
día después de que el presidente vaivén
pidiera un juez federal que tumbara la
ley ya que ésta permite incluso a
ciudadanos particulares perseguir a los
implicados en un aborto con multas de
hasta diez mil dólares algo que byd en
ella condenan septiembre
y lo más pernicioso de la ley de texas
es que crea una especie de sistema de
vigilancia en la que la gente recibe
recompensas por perseguir
esto es ridículo casi ante américa no no
es la primera vez que un estado intenta
sacar adelante una legislación así y
ahora muchos piensan en usar el modelo
de texas como ejemplo